[موسيقى]
[تصفيق
] عاد السحر للأفضل أو للأسوأ ،
ونتطلع إلى رؤيتك قريبًا في منتجع والت
ديزني وورلد ديزني وورلد في
أورلاندو يعيد افتتاح حدائقه الترفيهية
للجمهور في نهاية هذا الأسبوع بعد
فتحهما فقط حاملي التذكرة السنوية في
وقت سابق هذا  في الأسبوع ، قال أحد الضيوف
إنه يحب أن تكون الحشود أصغر حتى
الآن ، يقول موقع ديزني على الإنترنت إن اقتباسه
أعاد تصور تجربة ديزني حتى
نتمكن جميعًا من الاستمتاع بالسحر بمسؤولية ، لكن
الخبراء الطبيين يحذرون بالفعل من
إعادة افتتاح Disneyworld في وسط
دولة أصبحت الآن واحدة  من أسوأ
بؤر فيروس كورونا هو دعوة
الكارثة لمن لا يريد أن يكون
في أسعد مكان على وجه الأرض في وقت
نشعر فيه جميعًا بالتوتر ويمكن أن
نستخدم بعض المرح ، المشكلة هي أن عالم
ديزني سيكون أسعد مكان على
وجه الأرض  بالنسبة لفيروس كورونا على موقعها الإلكتروني
ومقاطع الفيديو الترويجية ، تطرح
ديزني جميع الخطوات التي تتخذها
لضمان سلامة الضيوف
والموظفين الذين تسميهم أعضاء فريق التمثيل
قبل دخول الضيوف ، سيخضع الضيوف
لفحص درجة الحرارة بدون
موازين الحرارة التي تعمل باللمس وتقول ديزني إنها لن
تسمح لأي شخص بدرجة حرارة 100
نقطة 4 درجات فهرنهايت أو أعلى.
في أماكن تناول الطعام ،
توجد مطهرات الأيدي وأحواض الغسيل في
كل مكان في المتنزهات
وسيتم تطهير الفنادق باستمرار
ويجب على كل شخص فوق سن الثانية
ارتداء قناع للوجه.
صحيح في
ضمان سلامة العمال ،
توقعنا أن تستمر ديزني في
أخذ توصيات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
والتوصيات والمراسيم المحلية
ويعتقد مات هوليس أن ديزني فعلت
ذلك حتى الآن
لكن نقابة أخرى تمثل
فناني ديزني تقول إن ديزني لم
تختبر فناني الأداء بشكل صحيح يصفها بأنها
مخزية  تقول ديزني إن Union رفضت
بروتوكولات السلامة الخاصة بها وخرقت
يقول خبراء المفاوضات إن اعتماد ديزني على الضيوف في
أن يتم تأديبهم عند ارتداء الأقنعة
والتباعد لا يكون مؤكدًا ،
وهناك مخاوف أخرى ليس من الواضح بالنسبة لي
أنه في كل هذه الجولات الداخلية ،
اتخذوا الإجراءات اللازمة
لتهوية
وترشيح الهواء.  هناك حاجة
للحفاظ على هذه المساحات الداخلية آمنة عندما
يكون لديك هذه المساحات الداخلية ، لديك الكثير
من الأشخاص في رحلة معينة ،
لديك أشخاص يصرخون في تلك الرحلة ، إنها
مجرد وصفة لكارثة
ولا يعتقد الخبراء الطبيون أن هذا التكتيك
المالكون في اليابان يستخدمون سيعملون في
ديزني وورلد ،
ذكرت صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال أن
المديرين التنفيذيين في بارك في اليابان يطلبون من العملاء
عدم الصراخ بصوت عالٍ أثناء الركوب خوفًا
من نقل القطرات ، ولكن أن يقتبسوا
صراخًا داخل قلبك